hier schmort Argentiniens stolz
Rindfleisch aus den Weiten der Pampa auf
dem Grill in buenesides Küchenchef
romanardi ist im Stress wie jeden Abend
obwohl Argentinien eine Wirtschaftskrise
und extreme Inflation erlebt kommen die
Leute zu ihm zum
Essen es ist kaum zu glauben schauen Sie
unser Grill ist voller Fleisch die Leute
gönnen sich etwas sie kommen weiter zum
Fleisch essen aber die Leute haben immer
weniger Geld warum geben Sie es hier aus
sie essen heute das was sie heute
bezahlen können ob sie das morgen noch
können wissen Sie
nicht unsere Esskultur ist alles was uns
bleibt sagen sie hier so wie im lodeesus
sieht es in fast allen guten Restaurants
der Stadt aus sie sind voll als gäbe es
kein Morgen und das stimmt gewissermaßen
auch leider können wir unser Geld nicht
sparen weil unsere Währung ständig an
Wert verliert was wir heute nicht
ausgeben ist morgen weniger wert deshalb
treffen wir uns lieber mit Freunden und
genießen ein gutes
Essen die große Mehrheit der Argentinier
aber kann sich das Genießen nicht mehr
leisten die Krise trifft vor allem die
Mittelschicht für sie wird es immer
schwieriger den Alltag zu bewältigen
immer wenn Ernestina fritayon zum
Einkaufen geht begleitet sie die Angst
vor dem
Preisschild gestern noch bist du mit
1000 Pesos losgegangen und hast zwei
Sachen gekauft und mus sch mehr
geldehmen weil es nicht meh re zweimal
wöchentlich montags und mittwochs
erhöhen die Zwischenhändler die Preise
und die Ladenbesitzer müssen mitziehen
die geldscheinbündel werden größer ihr
Wert immer kleiner heute kann Ernestina
ihren Tee noch
bezahlen der Tee ist etwas teurer als
letzte Woche als ich welchen gekauft
habe aber so ist das
eben Erna studiert doch das Versprechen
Bildung einen sozialen Aufstieg
garantiert gilt für ihre Generation
nicht mehr deshalb hat sie einen
folgenschweren Entschluss gefasst wie
sie uns später erzählen
wird 10 km weiter südlich im Vorort
aveaneda bleibt kein Platz für
Zukunftspläne für Ezekiel Sosa zählt
allein das Tagwerk gemeinsam mit seinem
zehnjährigen Sohn Martin und seiner
schwangeren Frau Romina macht er sich
jeden Tag auf sie sind cartonerus
Müllsammler wie es so viele von ihnen
gibt
buen Menschen am unteren Ende der
Gesellschaft haben keine Hilfe wir
machen das jeden Tag um zu essen um zu
überleben das Wetter gut ist haben wir
Glück denn wenn es regnet oder wir
nichts finden müssen wir betteln
gehen mehr als ein Drittel der
argentinia lebt unterhalb der
Armutsgrenze jeder zehte lebt ohne
gesicherte
Ernährung els Familie ernährt sich
teilweise aus dem
Abfall hier haben wir schon Mayonnaise
Marmelade so sammeln wir etwas zusammen
die Leute schmeißen das weg und wir
essen es in der Wirtschaftskrise ist ihr
Überleben noch einmal schwieriger
geworden weil weniger konsumiert wird
gibt es auch weniger Müll den sie
sammeln und weiterverkaufen können
selbst ganz unten nimmt der Abstieg kein
Ende wie viel ist das wert was sie hier
im Wagen
habenes
P umgerechnet etwa 50 Cent dafür gibt es
einen Leib Brot und das ist das was
zählt an die Politik und die anstehende
Präsidentschaftswahl will eekiel gar
nicht
denken wir sind die Wahlen ehrlich
gesagt egal soll doch regieren wer will
mir hilft sowieso keiner seit ich ein
kleiner Junge bin ziehe ich durch die
Straßen und sammle Wertstoffe lebe vom
Recycling von dem was ich
zusammenriege das ist mein
Leben und doch hat er mit seinen 3
Jahren noch Träume eines Tages will er
seinen eigenen Laden aufmachen für den
An und Verkauf von
Rohstoffen in ein paar Tagen wird
gewählt in Argentinien seit Jahrzehnten
wechseln sich links und rechts ab ohne
große Veränderungen doch nun wird das
Feld der bekannten Gesichter aufgemischt
von einem
Quereinsteiger ein Wirtschaft
Wissenschaftler fällt auf mit einer
Rhetorik die an Donald Trump und Co
erinnert wir gegen alle anderen sein
Markenzeichen ist die Kettensäge mit der
er die etablierte Politik zu Kleinholz
verarbeiten will etwa indem er
verspricht Ministerien
abzuschaffen Bildungsministerium reine
Indoktrination weg damit
Verkehrsministerium weg damit
Gesundheitsministerium weg damit und so
weiter in den Umfragen liegt m vorne
seine Position
undarchtisch was er wirklich will weß
niemand so genau aber das ist egal
Hauptsache kein weiter so sagen viele
Wähler es gibt ein Misstrauen gegenüber
der Regierung weil die Regierung als
eine Instanz wahrgenommen wird die einem
ständig Schaden zufügt vor der man sich
in Acht nehmen muss das erklärt warum
das Misstrauen in die Regierung bei
diesen Wahlen der eigentliche Sieger
sein
wird Koch den Tee den Siegen
gekauu Politik ist auch hier Thema ihr
Freund Luciano will m wählen wir wollen
einfach einen Wechsel selbst wenn man
dazu alles kaputt machen muss die
anderen Politiker machen eh einfach
weiter so bekommen wir wenigstens eine
Veränderung das heißt aber von allen
schlechten Optionen die schlechteste zu
wählen nein es ist einfach etwas Neues
ja klar so oder so beide glauben nicht
mehr an eine Zukunft in ihrem Land und
wollen auswandern Neuseeland Europa
hauptsache weg
man kann hier keine Zukunft planen sowas
wie ein Haus zu haben Kinder auf eine
gute Schule zu schicken all das ist
wahnsinnig
teuer als einzelner Mensch kann man
nichts
planen in den Restaurants von Buenos
Aires grillen und essen sie weiter an
gegen die Krise doch außerhalb dieser
kulinarischen Blase droht mehr und mehr
etwas wegzubrechen in
Argentinien